응.
앞으로 나아가면서 비트와
qubit은 우리가 활용할 수 있는 근본적인 계산의 기반이 될 거야
세상의 복잡한 문제들을
다룰 수 있는
그러니까 둘의 차이점을 이해해 보자
그리고 qubit의 힘이 어디서 나오는지도
왼쪽을 보면
이걸 표현하는 방법이 있고 이 다이어그램들을 쓸 거야
발표 전체에 걸쳐서
힘을 보여주기 위해 — 원 하나가 보이지
그리고 점 두 개, 점이 북극에 있으면
그게 0이고 남극에 있으면 1이야
그게 고전적인 비트의 두 가지 상태야, 이제 qubit은
양자 세계에서 정보의 단위야
그리고 여기서 우리는 그림을 가지게 되는데
구 안에 0도 1도 있어
그리고 이 중첩 상태로 있을 수 있어
우리한테 쓸 수 있는 특별한 트릭이 있어
이 구 안에 위치시킬 수 있는 것뿐만 아니라
이것들 하나하나가
마치 작은 달처럼 생각해봐
구 안에 있는 달, 그 달을 회전시킬 수 있어
여기서 보면
아래쪽 구가 약간 회전되어 있어
그래서 파란색이 조금 보이는 거야
그리고 분홍색도, 끝까지 회전시킬 수도 있어
여기 180도 회전한 게 있어
이렇게 우리는 위상이라는 개념을 가지고 있어, 양자는 우리에게
qubit에서 나타나는 세 가지 초능력을 줘
중첩의 힘
간섭의 힘
그리고 얽힘의 힘이야
그럼 살펴보자, 중첩의 원리는 사실
이해하기 꽤 쉬워
왼쪽 별모양을 보면
북극은 0, 남극은 1이야
이 두 상태를 더하면
0과 1을 동시에 가진 중첩 qubit이 돼
동시에 0이고 1인 북극과
남극이 있는 거야, 오른쪽 다이어그램도 같아
하지만 이제 작은 트릭을 해볼 거야
quantum gate를 적용할 거야
여기서 한 건 기억해봐
우린 이제 변경할 수 있어, 이제
이 작은 달들을 회전시킬 수 있잖아
그래서 100
80도 회전시켰고 이제 1이 됐어
그러면 0 더하기 1을 하면 결국
중첩 상태가 돼
근데 이건 다르다는 걸 봐
왼쪽 거는 여전히
0과 1이지만 이제 회전된 상태야
1에 대해서, 이건 굉장히 강력해질 거야
두 번째로 정말 흥미로운 걸 활용하기 위해서인데
바로 간섭의 원리야
이건 고전적인 비트 세계에서는 할 수 없는 연산이야
여기 이 예시에서 우리는
왼쪽에 0과 1 더하기
우리가 만든 새로운 상태가 있어
그것도 역시 0과 1인데
이 회전된 달이 있어, 이걸 하면 이제
두 상태를 간섭시킬 수 있어
그리고 정말 흥미로운 일이 생겼어
1 상태가 상쇄됐어
그래서 0 상태만 남았어
그건 우리가 상태들을 간섭시켰기 때문이야
그러면 지금 우리한테 있는 다음 기회는
얼마나 많은 상태를 만들 수 있냐는 거야
양자에서 아름다운 건 지수적으로 많은
상태를 만들 수 있다는 거야, 5개의 qubit을 가진 시스템을 보자
이 경우에 이 qubit들을
독립적인 qubit들로 나타내고 있어, 왼쪽에서 보이지
0과 1들이 곱해지고 있어, 우리한테 5개가 있어
그러니까 우리가 만들 수 있는 상태의 수는
오른쪽 구에 표현된 양자 컴퓨터에서
2의 거듭제곱이야
우리가 가진 qubit의 수만큼, 이 경우엔 5야
그러니까 2의 5제곱은 32개의 상태야
그래서 저 작은 달 32개가 보이는 거야
이 경우엔 위상을 포함시키지 않았다는 걸 봐
전부 분홍색이야, 양자 세계에서
얽힘이라고 불리는 이 속성을 사용하는 강력한 점은
이제 상태를 만들 수 있다는 거야
오른쪽에 표현된 것처럼
분홍색과
파란색의 조합이 있는데, 그 상태는
독립적인 곱으로는 설명이 안 돼
이 5개의 qubit으로는
32개의 상태가 있으니까
이게 말해주는 건 실제로 굉장히 심오한 거야